in the summer of 2021 Sam bankman freed
gets on a zoom call with partners of
Sequoia capital a venture capital firm
these were people who had invested in
apple Google Instagram and I could go on
point is Sam was here to talk about FTX
in the hopes of convincing Sequoya to
invest money into the company a few
months after that Zoom call they lead
round of Investments for FTX which total
almost a billion do and a year after
that Zoom call 2 months before the
collapse Capital releases this 45 page
article titled Sam bankman freed has a
savior complex and maybe you should too
the article goes on to talk about Sam's
commitment to the effective altruism
movement and when the author sits down
with him for an interview he becomes
convinced that Sam is the real deal and
may very well become the world's first
trillionaire sooya wasn't some
exceptional case you know they were just
one of the many big institutional names
investing into FTX